I am very impressed with the skill of some of these,
I guess this is the print primitive hunting movement with spears and see that's,
I think you should,
I think you should be really careful about anything that you do that's not that
accurate.
That's that's an issue.
Yeah.
That's a giant issue at,
but bowser extremely accurate.
Right,
and there's guys that can shoot a paper plate at 120 yards every single time.
They could shoot a little plate like that.
They'll,
they'll bet their life.
They could drop an Arrow into that at 120 yards every single time.
You can get good at that.
You can get,
if you have good technique and a reasonable control of your emotions and your
anxiety and sure in the heart,
in the heat of the moment,
you don't ever shoot anything in 120 yards though.
You're shooting at things 30 yards,
40 yards,
and the degree of success is very high with skilled hunters.
If you,
they're ethical and they're shy,
they're shot decisions.
That primitive stuff is like,
why?
Why are you throwing spears?
Like,
what do you,
what are you doing?
You're trying to prove that you're better than people that use a bow and arrow.
Like this is not an accurate or effective thing.
I mean,
it kind of is,
but you have to be like five yards,
10 yards.
Like what do you gotta be 15 yards max?
Even then,
I think part of the thrill of it for them is putting themselves in danger.
There's a little bit of that if you're shooting,
oh,
you're going after a bear.
Yeah.
Like I've seen some of these things filmed where the person looks like,
you know,
they're up in there,
I don't know what to call it,
their little Tristan,
Tristan.
And that doesn't look like they're putting a lot of risk.
But some of these people are clearly getting off on this is the primal hunt.
Right.
And this is,
they're going backwards into something where the animal could surprise them.
And what I,
what I wanted to do is I want it to reacquaint myself with,
you know,
now that I can,
I can watch somebody actually in that moment,
um,
try to figure out what my ethics around hunting where and I thought that I had
prepared myself and I just,
I thought when I,
when I saw you,
um,
find out where Joe is.
Um,
cause I have no question.
Knowing your ethics and how you think that you would have a very subtle
perspective on all these different kinds of kills,
which sorts of animals.
Yeah.
If you get to spears,
yeah,
you're in a weird place.
Like,
like you say,
oh I only spear wild pigs.
We're trying to get rid of them anyway.
Okay,
well that's,
we're in a weird place where in a weird place because a ethically,
I think you have two choices,
three choices.
You three choices are rifle,
which is number one ethically,
realistically,
because if you shoot something with a rifle,
you,
you can be really accurate,
like out to a hundred yards a hundred percent of the time.
Like unless it's crazy windy out or there's some weird conditions,
altitude can affect ballistics but not that much out to a hundred yards.
You're fucking deadly.
If you have a really good control,
squeezing the trigger,
you're not jerking everything and not panicking,
then Beau is second,
you know,
bow,
it requires way more practice.
Way,
way more fine tuning of your motor skills,
but it's still possible.
Okay.
Then you have crossbow,
which is even more effective than a bow.
Faster,
more feet per second,
faster feet per second so that it travels at a flat line because it's going
quicker before it drops.
The ball drop at the same speed.
Right?
Bullets and arrows all drop at the same speed.
They just don't get get there at the same speed.
Okay,
so in the same amount of time,
like if I'm shooting something at a hundred yards with a bow I am aiming with,
with a site that is calculating for the fact that the Arrow is going to drop
significantly in the time that it takes if it's going 280 feet per second is
like a normal speed for a good bow.
The good heavy Arrow that's 280 feet per second,
that goes a hundred yards.
Okay?
A bullet is going to go 100 yards far quicker,
but in the same amount of time it takes that Arrow to get to that target.
The bullet is going to drop the same amount as the Arrow and that's what most
people don't understand.
So a crossbow is more ethical because it's more accurate.
It's this have fewer moving parts.
You could accurately sit it on a rest and just squeeze the trigger easier to
manipulate and the,
the Arrow is traveling faster,
so it's called a bolt traveling faster.
Sotal drop less after that chick gets squirrely after that,
it's like you're throwing spears.
Okay,
you got,
what do you got?
An Ad Ladol okay.
All right,
well you can kill things with it and people have done it,
but it gets to how accurate are you and what is,
what's your ethical brain?
Right?
Like an ethical ranch for a really good hunter with a bow and arrow is probably
80 yards.
You get me a bed,
maybe it's a moose 90 yards,
something big.
But with a spear,
like what do you got?
You got 10 yards.
So you know why that's the question.
Are you doing it for meat?
Are you doing it because,
um,
is this your Mount Everest?
You want to kill a pig with a spear and are you saying that as pig is not worth
as much?
So you should be able to kill it with a spear cause these are all weird.
These are all weird decisions that were decisions and people make those with
bears.
They make those decisions with black bears,
like people that live where they consider them nuisances.
Th they,
they kill them.
I mean they used to be,
you still allow them to shoot.
Uh,
you still allowed to hunt,
used to be allowed to hunt black bears with a spear in Alberta until a big
scandal a couple of years ago where a guy filmed
self doing that.
He shot a bear,
he killed a bear or rather with spear and was hooting and hollering and people
got ahold of the video and thought it was disgusting and protested it.
And,
uh,
people,
from underarmour dropped his a wife from there,
you know,
they had this sort of a sponsorship deal with them and uh,
it,
it ignited,
it caused a rift in the hunting community.
Some people think you should be able to hunt with a rock.
I don't care what you hunt with Sheila Hunt with anything and other people like,
hmm,
okay,
but what are we doing?
Are we just going out to get meat or are we putting on a macho performance of
our [inaudible]?
This is exactly what I wanted to get at.
Which is if you know that the population has to be controlled and you want the
meat,
yeah.
Then it makes sense to me that you have to open yourself up to some of the
pleasure of the kill.
That makes some sense.
But what I saw just like flipped me out because it wasn't,
it was,
it was above and beyond.
Yeah.
I saw a spear and yeah,
and other things and you know,
I was impressed by the,
some of the skill,
I'm impressed by some of the bravery,
but like why,
right,
right.
And doing it to populate your control,
you're doing it for the,
this was a surprise to me.
I got kind of sickened by it.
Surprising.
It's not surprising,
you know?
I mean I think if you,
if you were there,
you'd probably be even more conflicted because you actually were there and the
presence of the thing dying,
you know,
watching a bare die on a a video is one thing.
But being there alive when they die as a completely different thing,
um,
it's,
it's a very complicated thing because we have these deep set
emotional connections to certain animals that my friend Steve Rinella,
who's going to be actually on tomorrow,
he calls them,
um,
charismatic megafauna that we have this different view of certain animals bears
in particular.
But if you use the animal respectfully,
respectfully,
and you kill it ethically and you do,
I don't have any problem with hunting bears.
In fact,
I think it's actually an,
and that's it.
It really is a necessary task.
It.
It's something that even if you don't like to hunt bears,
if you're living in a place like Alberta,
you probably should hunt bears because you should do your part.
There's a lot of them out there and you know,
one of the things that becomes,
uh,
an interesting relationships or relationship between the moose hunters and the
deer hunters and the bear hunters that they have.
Kind of those smart ones have come to an understanding that even if I don't hunt
bear,
I need those people out there doing it.
Okay,
but it's how do you do it and why you doing it?
I think I've seen animals die very quickly with a bone arrow.
They die very quickly.
I've never seen animal die with a spear.
I don't think it's necessary,
but I don't want to be the person that tells you you can't do it.
If you have an ethical range of five yards and you only hunt bear with a spear
at five yards and you kill it immediately,
you hit it and kill it.
You're right.
Then you're right.
It's not based on the method.
It's based on what,
what are the ethical around the time I appreciate it.
So I would kind of be a hypocrite because even though I can ethically kill
something at 40 yards or just figuring out what the number is,
depending on the size of the animal,
right.
Um,
even though I can do that,
I could do it way easier with a rifle.
So why am I using a bow and Arrow?
Why do I want to make it more difficult?
Why am I making it more challenging?
Why am I requiring myself to practice more questions?
You're very self aware.
It's a very important question to ask because if I was just doing it just for
the meat,
I would probably use a rifle,
right?
Yeah.
I think that that,
that,
that part of it has to do with the primal association with the kill.
And then the key question is how do you want to indulge that?
What is the set and setting,
blah,
blah.
So that was the,
that was the thing that I found shocking.
This is that I had thought,
you know,
I understood something about the need to control population.
It's the effect which really killed me.
Well again,
we're talking about bears,
you know,
it's not just bears other animals as well.
Yeah.
I mean I saw,
I don't want to focus more on it necessarily,
but it's just a question I had to ask you because I sort of,
I was very surprised by my own reaction.
Well,
a lot of it
people are taking issue.
My good friend Ben O'brien,
who's a brilliant writer who's actually also a hunter,
um,
is uh,
advocating that people stop taking what he calls grip and grins with a grip.
And Grin is like,
say if you shot a beautiful deer,
you're holding the deer up by the antlers and you're smiling and he's advocating
that those photos are problematic because people who don't hunt look at it like
you're some bloodthirsty asshole that's super happy that something died.
And that's not,
even though that's not how the people feel when they're taking those photos,
what there are is happy that something which is very difficult,
which you know,
especially if we're using a bow,
most people go home empty handed.
It's requires too much fitness,
physical fitness because you're going up and down these mountains.
It requires too much accuracy and training and technique and archery.
Most people fuck it up and then there's dealing with anxiety.
Most people fuck it up.
But after it's all over,
there's this great feeling of elation.
Right?
You did it.
I can't believe it came together.
Wow.
Cause it was probably not going to come together and people get happy.
And these are people again that already except hunting.
Now if you take someone who is an animal rights activist or someone who deeply
appreciates animals and then you show him that photo,
they have a completely different association with what that photo means would
that photo means is,
here's an asshole who's a trophy hunt.
Okay.
The shots.
Let me get my thing.
I don't know any species that celebrates a kill for food with glee chips.
Do Choda.
Sorry.
You're right.
Yeah.
When they kill a monkey,
they get pretty happy.
Well then they do it socially,
and then they share it,
uh,
you know,
through altruism,
and he's screaming each other.
Yeah.
Yay.
So that's the chimps are my least favorite species,
almost of all their wholesale.
Terrifying.
Worse.
Yeah.
They're terrifying little fuckers.